Forschungsteams weltweit finden schon seit jahren immer mehr beispiele dafür dass wir tiere wohl lange gnadenlos unterschätzt haben nicht nur menschen darf man menschen
können probleme lösen individuelle entscheidungen treffen und langfristig planen sondern auch einige andere tierarten das stellt die
weltsicht der biologie so komplett auf den kopf denn offensichtlich haben wir uns selbst lange zeit als spezielles
überbewertet welche experimente zeigen dass tiere viel mehr sind als reine reiz reaktions maschinen und wie sich
forschungsteams diese erkenntnisse beispielsweise beim bau intelligenter maschine zu sitzen machen wollen jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction das video sind zusammenarbeit mit der richtig richtig guten zeitschrift technology review entstanden am ende habe ich ein gratisexemplar
für euch herzlich willkommen
Die große frage die über allem steht ist das verhalten einer tierart das ergebnis eines biologischen
automatismus oder aber steckt dort die planung
hartnäckigkeit ja vielleicht sogar die individuelle entscheidungen eines tieres dahinter immer mehr in diensten finden forschungsteams weltweit
jedenfalls dafür dass wir die geistigen leistungen anderer lebewesen sehr
unterschätzt und uns selbst total überschätzt haben dazu ein beispiel
ein französisches forschungsteam konnte erst vor kurzem zeigen dass honigbienen
nicht nur in der lage sind kleine mengen zu vergleichen sondern dass die tiere sogar das konzept der zahlen 0 verstehen in dem experiment
wurden die bienen mit zuckerlösung belohnt wenn sie das bild auswählten dass die wenigste ansatz als elementen zeigte
wenn die tiere also zwischen einem bild mit drei oder sechs elementen wählen konnten sollten sie im besten fall dass mit den drei elementen
das forschungsteam war mehr als überrascht als sie bienen sich für das bild ohne punkte also für
0-elemente entschieden es scheint also so als wüssten die bienen das 0 auch eine zahl ist kinder brauchen jahre
um das zu verstehen denn die null ist neurologisch gesehen eine riesige herausforderung
dazu adrian meyer von der university melbourne der an dem experiment beteiligt war
es ist relativ einfach für neuronen auf reize wie licht oder die anwesenheit eines objektes zu reagieren
aber wie können wir oder sogar einen sekt verstehen was nichts ist wie kann ein gehirn nichts
darstellen dass auch bienen also insekten dafür die nötige intelligenz
haben ist neu etwas länger wissen wir schon dass auch vögel und affen dazu in der lage sind aber dass
insekten das können also das zeigen auch experimente mit hummeln die an eine versteckte blüte gelangen sollten und gab erlernten an einem faden zu ziehen
doch woher kommt dieses intelligente verhalten hat es viel weniger mit höheren hirnfunktionen
zu tun als wir bislang vermutet haben ein unfassbar spannender aspekt für die entwicklung künstlicher intelligenz den roboter beispielsweise
sollen sich ja in äußerst komplexen umgebungen zurechtfinden dazu da
eine straße zu überqueren ist für erwachsenen menschen einfach wir verstehen wenn es keine autos fahrräder oder
straßenbahn gehen aber was ist null wie stellen wir dies für so viele komplexe objekt lassen darf um
entscheidungen in komplexen umgebungen zu treffen wenn bienen 0 mit einem gehirn von weniger als einer million euro
wahrnehmen können deutet das darauf hin dass es einfache effiziente wege gibt ki neue tricks beizubringen
einige forscher und forscherinnen glauben auch an die so genannte
intelligenz ohne repräsentation ein verhalten das auf einer direkten aber dennoch nicht rein automatischen verarbeitung von informationen
resultiert ohne dass lebewesen dazu ein abstraktes konzept verstehen müssten einige
forschungsteams nehmen in diesem zusammenhang beispielsweise an das spinnennetze ein teil des kognitiven
systems der tiere sind und die netze um so straffer sein
jäger die tiere seien der fang von beute wird damit wahrscheinlich dazu ein verfechter dieser theorie der australische biologen
schenk
kognition ist von zentraler bedeutung für die intelligenz kommt aber in mehr
variationen vor als die üblichen theorie besagt für viele verhalten forscher und forscherinnen steht jedenfalls fest
sowie die klassische biologie die welt mit ihren hierarchien beschreibt ist sie so nicht mehr gültig denn demnach soll die
intelligenz eines tieres umso kleiner sein je weiter es vom stammbaum des menschen
entfernt ist so müssten also schafe klüger sein als vögel denn diese sind keine säugetiere es gibt allerdings nicht weniger
experimente die das gegenteil beweisen krähen vögel zum beispiel sind nicht nur in der lage sich selbst im spiegel zu erkennen und werkzeuge zu nutzen
sie können auch langfristig planen dazu
jonas rose von der ruhr-uni bochum von
herrn weiß man dass sie futter für die zukunft verstecken wenn es in einen käfig zum beispiel zum frühstück immer
mehlwürmer gibt in dem anderen immer erdnüsse und man den eichelhäher am abend vorher erdnüsse und mehlwürmer anbietet
verstecken sie genau das futter dass es in diesem käfig am nächsten morgen nicht geben wird in
experimenten konnten sie mit hilfe von mikroelektroden im gehirn der tiere zeigen dass das arbeitsgedächtnis der vögel mit dem von affen
vergleichbar ist
zudem hat das forschungsteam weitere studien in arbeit die ein weiteres überraschendes ergebnis
haben demnach denken vögel auf dieselbe art und weise wie tiere mit einer gehirnrinde
also nur mit weniger ressourcen
dabei verfügen vögel überhaupt nicht über diese schicht des gehirns auch tauben sind cleverer als die meisten von uns wohl glauben sie können
sinnvolle wörter von sinnfreien
buchstabenkombinationen unterscheiden und diese tricks müssen die tiere wohl nicht einmal lernen entenküken erklären das erste lebewesen
dass sie in ihrem enden leben sehen als ihre mutter egal ob es eine entenmama ist oder aber gegenstände
oxford so logan prägten so entenküken auf zwei blaue kugeln die an den enden
verwaltungen danach entschieden sich die küken für die identischen formen selbst wenn sie kugeln mit verschiedenen farben und
gegenständen mit derselben form aber mit fremden farben zur auswahl hatten doch das macht eine äußerst wichtige sache in diesem
zusammenhang klar dazu martin trostel einer der oxford forscher wir wollten zeigen dass jedes system das beliebige gegenstände
identifizieren kann auch dazu in der lage ist
abstrakte kategorien zu lernen das bedeutet nicht dass die enten ein abstraktes konzept
gelernt haben alles was wir sagen können ist dass sie sich so verhalten als ob sie ein abstraktes konzept gelang captain
heißt also auf vorsicht vor überinterpretation in tierexperimenten sollte man nicht vorschnell
menschenähnliche intelligenz in einem verhalten reinlesen doch warum haben
säugetiere dann so viele nervenzellen wenn tiere mit weniger nervenzellen ähnlich intelligentes verhalten zeigen können die erklärung dafür
die ergebnisse scheinen ähnlich zu sein doch für spezielle leistungen in bestimmten lebensverhältnissen braucht es wohl doch mehr neuronen
das nervensystem der tiere produziert jederzeit
mögliche verhaltensweisen mit vielen neuronen generiertes jedoch auch besonders viele verhaltens
möglichkeiten um dann durch versuch und irrtum eine lösung zu finden
intelligenz also als eine art
modulbaukasten mit verschiedenen geistigen
fähigkeiten das sieht auch born brems von der universität regensburg so menschliche intelligenz ist
einzigartig einzigartig in dem sinne in dem auch die morphologie eines nagetiers
einzigartig ist heißt also die eben genannten beispiele sind gar nicht so faszinierend weil sie zeigen wie
intelligent vögel oder bieten wirklich sind sondern weil sie zeigen
wenig neuronaler rechenpower
spezielle geistige leistungen möglich sind für intelligentes verhalten in maschinen hieße das dann für höhere kognitive
fähigkeiten ist kein großes weit entwickeltes gehirn notwendig intelligentes verhalten
ließe sich sogar in ein kleines roboter hirn einpflanzen ein superrechner ist demnach nicht mehr notwendig und so kommen neuen
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen und
computerwissenschaftler wissenschaftlerinnen zusammen um ihre disziplin zu vereinen das unternehmen gibt meint hat ein neuronales netz entwickelt das
erfahrung für allgemein hat es probiert wahllos aktionen aus um ein problem zu lösen
erfolgreiche aktionen der software werden belohnt und sie wird dadurch immer besser einer der entwicklermesse
botton wink sieht dieses metall learning als
wesentliche schlüssel zur künstlichen allgemeinen intelligenz
denn unsere welt besitzt eine spezifische eigenart wir erleben niemals dieselbe situation
zweimal aber wir erleben auch niemals eine komplett neue situation
jedes intelligente system muss also die fähigkeit besitzen die
erfahrungen der vergangenheit zu nutzen um sie auf elegante und schnelle weise auf neue aufgaben zu übertragen
als großes ziel der ki forschung sieht er die entwicklung einer umgebung in der die kühlsysteme
leben lernen und trainieren können den umgekehrten weg geht ein forschungsteam aus deutschland aus dem echten leben rein in einen daran
angelehntes computerprogramm hier wurden modelle gebaut die an die sogenannten pilzkörper von bienen angelehnt waren dort wo die
neuronalen netzwerke bei den bienen zusammenlaufen hier wurde nur festgelegt ob und wenn ja wie stark zwei nervenzellen miteinander
verbunden sind dazu einer der forscher laschet gab
dann haben wir ausprobiert was passiert wenn man informationen durch diese netze pumpt sie also gewissermaßen
verschiedenen umwelt die molli aussetzt
22 juli wurden zunächst trainiert einer positiv nämlich an blumenduft der vielen tollen bringt und ein duft der sich am ende nicht wirklich
lohnt dem entwickelten netz wurden dann neue aber ähnliche dürfte vorgesetzt und tatsächlich wie vielen hirn simulationen
bevorzugte einen duft der in dem belohnten geruch am ähnlichsten war und der gleichzeitig maximal weit weg von den
bestraften lag so wurde also der
gesamtnutzen optimiert was die forscher auch als das pik schiffs verhalten bezeichnen das fazit das experiment ist
erstaunlich und soll so auf viele weitere
kg übertragen werden damit diese auf einer art intelligent werden wie sich die meisten von uns heutzutage nicht mehr im traum vorstellen
können dazu der zoologe mattino trasse wir sind umgeben von
unglaublich vielen gehirn die in der lage sind
aufgaben zu lösen die wir gern von maschinen lösen lassen wird er nennt das beispiel der ameisen und wer weiß vielleicht
sind ja autonom fahrende autos da schon bald so intelligent wie ameisen
ok vielen dank an die redaktion von technology review
die dieses mind blowing thema für uns recherchiert hat hier bekommt ihr einfach draufklicken ein
gratis heft unter drunter geht's weiter mit einem anderen thema von technology review was soll das erstes schwimmendes
atomkraftwerk bis dann
bleibt dran